friends and family paid tribute to the
late great dmx
he will rest in power rest in love
but most of all he will rest in peace
e.t has learned that beyonce and jay-z
were among the thousands of mourners
bidding their final farewell to the late
rapper
at saturday's memorial service
dmx's music played as his red casket
made its way to barclay center
atop a custom monster truck a source
tells e.t
kanye west produced the event with his
yeezy team
his sunday service choir performed
kanye also enlisted the help of designer
valenciaga
to create a 200 tribute shirt it sold
out in 24 hours and raised a million
dollars for dmx's family
our father is an icon the funeral
service was attended by alicia keys
and included heartbreaking remembrances
by his family
and seven of his 15 children i wish
things were different
and that he could see me graduate
college i wanted him to see me
graduate high school i will be 10 next
month
and it makes me sad that my dad will
never be able
to sing or say happy birthday to me ever
[Music]
again